اول شيء الشركات التقنيه خلال السنوات
الماضيه لو رجعنا لاخر سنتين ترى ما كانت
فيها ابتكارات جدا كبيره كان في حديث عن
عالم الميته فيرس والواقع الافتراضي وغيره
لكن ما شفنا شيء لكنه قبلها ترى ما في شيء
كل الشركات حاليا تبحث عن المفقود عن
الشيء اللي ممكن هم يسوونه يعني ابل من
فتره طويله تقدم الهواتف الذكيه لكنه ما
قدمت خلال السنوات الماضيه اللي ابتكارات
جدا محدوده فصار في تباطؤ في النمو ما في
منافسه جدا كبيره ما بين الشركات زي اللي
كنا شوفوا في عام 2014 2013 كان في شركات
العامله في نظام الاندرويد والشركات
العامه كان في تنافس كبير واطلاقات وخدمات
وابتكارات مختلفه لكن وصلت الاجهزه الى
نقطه معينه لا يمكن ان نتنبا ويش راح يكون
في بعدها بعض الشركات التقنيه تفكر ان
تكون الاجهزه الملبسه النظارات الساعات
غيره هي المستقبل بعض الشركات تفكر ان
المنازل الذكيه راح تكون هي هي المحصه
المحطه اللي ممكن تستثمر فيها وتوصل الى
شكل اكبر لذلك فيس بوك او جوجل وابل اطلقه
منصات ماترز اللي تسرع من تبني تقنيات
الحديثه في المنازل الذكيه فلذلك الشركات
التقنيه حاليا وصلت الى مرحله الذروه ما
يعرفونهم ويش راح يكون مستقبل المرحله هذه
هل المستقبل راح يكون في المنازل الذكيه
هل المستقبل راح يكون
المستقبل راح يكون في الواقع المعزز هل
المستخدم راح يكون في السيارات هل ممكن
يكون فيرس ولا لانه تجربتهم او همم تجربه
الفيسبوك كانت مغامره غير ناجحه وغير
محسوبه حتى الان مغامره فيسبوك غير ناجحه
لكن لازم نعرف ونتكلم عن شيء دائما
المغامرات اللي تكون في البدايه قد ما
تكون ناجحه بشكل جدا كبير الشركات اول ما
طلع اول هاتف همم ذكي كانت مغامره غير
ناجحه للشركات نوكيا مثلا ديك السنوات
طلعت
هواتف او شركات هواتف بعدها تند الارث
اللي طلعته نوكيا وبعدين بدك تنتج هواتف
ذكيه اذا جينا نتكلم عن نفس هذا المنطق
واجينا نمسك على نفس هذا المنطق ونمشي
عليه قد يكون عالم الميتافيرس
قد يكون
قد يكون مو قد يكون الوقت المعزز سناب شات
مثلا ثلاث مرات
بشكل الماضي
بضمك مثال جدا بسيط شفت الفلاثر استخدمها
في سناب شات مثلا طوق الورد اللي الناس
كانت تستخدم قنوات الماضيه همم العدسات
اللي تضيف لك عالم حولك ترى
فلذلك الواقع المعزز هو يضيف شيء يضافي
موجود عندك لكن الواقع الافتراضي هو عالم
مختلف عن العالم
ثانيه
راح يكون اسمها 200 لان هذه منصه منصه
الواقع الافتراضي بالتالي لا يمكن توقع ما
هي الموجه القادم لشركات التقنيه
الموجه القادمه ام تاتي شركه من الخرج
من الصلاه التواصل اجتماعيه وصلت الى
مرحله ترى جدا جدا عاليه وما كان في تطور
اقدمه البديل اللي لهم مقدمه تجربه مختلفه
عن
التواصل الاجتماعي المختلفه واخذت حصه
كبيره المستخدمين من حول العالم الان
المنصات تقلد تك تك تقدم بعض المميزات
داخل همم داخلها مثل انستغرام اللي قدمت
نسخه المشابه لتكتكه غيرها فلذلك كل منصات
التواصل اجتماعيه حاليا تقتبس من بعضها
وينظرون امهم عارفين ايش المستقبل هيكون
موجود عندهم